um it it kind of made me wonder though
like why does anyone believe anything
you know like why are there witches out
there if if magic work why wouldn't we
we all be doing it right you know like w
just like that or you know why are there
like these monks who meditate for hours
and hours does that actually bring them
peace you know and I had a lot of
questions
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live we got a very
special guest today we have Haley Wolf
who's actually the granddaughter of the
owner of a major christian television
network but her story is interesting
because even though she was raised
Christian she ventured off into some
different areas new age and things like
that and when I heard her story I was
just like man your testimony is very
powerful and I know that our audience
needs to hear this because she's
actually written a book about her Story
coming out of that and some of the
really powerful points the facts that we
can trust the Bible apologetics really
helped you with this so Haley thank you
for coming 3 hours away and being with
us on the show to share your story so
tell us your story you were raised
Christian apparently I mean you your
grandfather is a a big name in in the
Christian World on television and I know
you you've been on some of those
Christian shows growing up were you ever
at a point where you were actually a
Believer as a child yeah um I was raised
is that way and so I just always assumed
that God existed and you know that Jesus
was our savior and I didn't really have
any doubts about that um yeah I was uh
traveling to different countries with my
Granda missionary stuff um yeah he would
go out um and speak and preach at
different places and uh traveled a lot
in our own country as well and so I was
exposed to a lot of that I went to
Christian Schools growing up um grade
school and high school and uh I'd say I
started kind of questioning things when
I became a teenager more like my late
teens um so I was what do you think kind
of triggered those questions cuz for me
I know that media had a big influence
like violent video games and MTV and I
was like that looks fun and to me I was
like I know no Christian supposed to be
out there on spring break but that looks
fun as Christianity just about not
having fun like what what things kind of
made you question so um I've always been
somebody who likes to learn about
everything I can and so I would
definitely say the internet had a lot to
do with that yeah different time period
I didn't have the internet the internet
once again right yep yep and so um you
know I was looking into things like
historical things and all that I really
like history and cultures and languages
and I saw a lot of atheists posting
things about like Richard Dawkins and
stuff yeah yeah and kind of like trying
to talk about why Christianity is
ridiculous to believe in and so I
remember I started listening on YouTube
to some of yeah like Richard Dawkins
Christopher Hitchens and they made sense
to me at the time and so I I was
questioning a lot really it was when I
turned 18 and you know I was in a very
sheltered kind of experience growing up
and so you know suddenly I'm 18 I'm
going out into the world getting a job
like all this stuff right and I started
running into you know other people with
other ways of thinking and um being
around a majority Christian growing up
and then it totally switches right right
you know now I'm around a bunch of
people who don't believe they're mostly
atheists and agnostics yeah and um even
Christians who believe differently than
what I was taught and all of that made
me question things like Christians that
go
drinking do you mind sharing a little
bit about um you're just growing up in
your home life I mean were you actively
involved in church every single weekend
did you guys have worships and things in
your home um are those things that were
present so uh um I would say we did go
to church just about every
week um I don't remember us doing a lot
in the home um like a lot of indepth
studying into various different things
no I don't I don't remember doing much
of that um I know like my mom um if she
was going to have something on the TV
like it would be usually something
educational right um and you know like
even Veggie Tales you know like whatever
right like Christian stuff right um but
I would say in the home there wasn't a
lot of in-depth
stuff um so it wasn't a like very
prominent always talked about kind of
you know thing inside of your home no
now I would hear my mom um say things uh
kind of like speaking against what
people were doing out in the world right
but um as I started you know questioning
and started learning more about other
people's ways of life it started
sounding judgmental to me interesting
they always love that angle you know
what I mean it's like why are you
telling me what to do but what's really
ironic is that they'll tell you what to
do all day long in the Christian space
right the whole world like loves to try
to steer the Christianity I like I've
seen a meme and somebody was like Only
God can judge me and the person was like
that should terrify you
yeah well so you mentioned your mom yeah
what about your dad is he in the picture
so um my
dad uh was in our house until I was
about 10 um and so my parents are
divorced um my dad did a good job of
like when we were young not trying to
say anything that would conflict with
what my mom would say but um so she was
a Believer yeah so my mom's always been
a Christian my dad was raised Christian
but um he's not a Christian and um and
so I know we would have conversations
when I was a teenager also and that had
a lot of influence on me as well cuz my
dad wasn't trying to tell me hey what
you believe is ridiculous or something
but he would ask me questions like well
what do you think about this does this
seem very nice you know and kind of you
know make me have to like wonder about
that now I did go ask people questions
other Christians try to understand these
things like hey I don't know how to
answer this question that this
non-believer has and what I found is um
a lot of the Christians I would talk to
also didn't have very great answers and
so it really made me start to wonder you
know um I would say after a lot of
exposure and listening and reading um
you know books by these prominent
atheist speakers eventually I found
myself actually having a hard time
believing in the Bible or anything like
that and it's not that I didn't want to
believe it cuz I actually did want to
believe it but I just couldn't um you
heard too many of the arguments that
sort of formulated the little grain of
sand in your mind and yeah and
unfortunately Christian's not having a
rebuttal and that's that was my
experience growing up too when I started
to have doubts I started asking
questions and Christians dro the ball
and that's why I love apologetics now
because now I'm like wow all this stuff
has been around and nobody told me this
stuff so I guess my question to both of
you would
be you
found
these arguments from atheists and stuff
and and you're saying specifically like
online on YouTube and you're finding all
this philosophy and stuff did you look
for the answers to your Christian
questions in the same
place yes I did um but it was very
difficult to do that online because
there's a lot of kinds of Christians a
lot of different answers to things sure
um so it it was more confusing I would
say um
but so like when it comes to there's two
different kinds of apologetics right
there's historical evidences of things
and you know archaeology and then
there's moral arguments um you know like
the problem of evil and those kinds of
things and so the problem was at the
time on the internet I couldn't find a
lot of historical stuff it's different
now but I couldn't find any like uh like
real evidence you know and um with the
Moral Moral arguments it seemed to
depend on your
denomination so that was confusing for
me as a young person yeah like we don't
need to follow the Ten Commandments
whatever none of them matter Jesus paid
for it all and that's it you know what I
mean it's like well why isn't everybody
just
debaucherous I mean clearly we as
Christians we all want to be good and we
try to follow what the Bible says you
know what I mean it's like the argument
of just saying oh those don't matter
anymore well if it doesn't matter why
would you try to be good well and that's
the thing right is I know um Paul talks
about I'm trying to remember where it
was he talks about um when you're
talking to people like the Gentiles
right you know going out and talking to
them um like not
arguing about yeah like that kind of
stuff but and see in this case it wasn't
you know that situation but when I'm out
there looking for like there's got to be
a specific answer and I'm wavering in my
faith you know it it made it difficult
because then I see oh like people don't
agree on this so how am I supposed to
know MH that was a difficult one um
but yeah so when when I was 18 at this
point you know having a hard time with
all of that I did get to the point where
I just couldn't believe anymore and I it
was so much so that I got comfortable
calling myself an atheist at that point
I was not open to any form of
spirituality I thought it was all
ridiculous um I was I'm always curious
to at that State of Mind mhm is it seems
kind of depressing to me
like does have all the fun you want to
and then you just die yeah but what a
depressing world if you're not having
fun then then you're then your entire
engagement becomes the pursuit of
pleasure y that's it that's like the
highest obtainable goal that you can as
a human achieve as much pleasure as
possible I think for me um I remember
when I finally it kind of like hit me I
I knew when it happened because my
mindset kind of changed in one setting
right um I remember I was driving on my
way to work and I was looking at how
beautiful everything was outside and um
you know I I had learned about Evolution
you know and like how everything not in
school because he grew up in Christian
School no but when I was like studying
and like got into the atheistic stuff a
lot of them teach Evolution which by the
way requires a lot of faith when you
really learn about it um big difference
between 1 billion and 500 billion years
just just throwing that out there yeah
but um so I was looking at everything
and just thinking like wow I could see
it you know I well I was trying to see
it at first right like could this happen
but I was starting to be able to kind of
see it that way like oh yeah you know
wow everything like evolves so pretty
you know pretty and at that point um
that's kind of when I had that moment of
not feeling God anymore and it was a
moment actually um where you know I it
felt like empty right but in my head I
was thinking not that it was sad but I
was thinking like wow you know there's
so much I don't understand there's so
much to learn about the world because I
was taught this way and this wasn't the
right way way so it actually felt like a
big door opened up where now oh you know
I have a lot to explore now you know um
it's interesting where that took me
though
because uh you know as an atheist and
like I was a hardcore atheist I did not
believe I wanted to ask that because I
yeah I see a lot of quote unquote
atheists too in my opinion are actually
Antichrist like I'm like you don't
believe in anything Supernatural but why
does your Facebook page have
anti-christian blasting Christians anti
I'm like that would be like me spending
all my time saying the Easter Bunny is
not true and I can prove it like if you
don't believe in these things why even
talk about them just live on with your
life and post here's a funny pet video
spending so much time trying to you're
evangelizing for Satan you're
evangelizing to try and make other
people doubt their faith did you get
into that camp because I did even I I
never consider myself an atheist more
agnostic but I really tried to make
other believers doubt their faith so um
I didn't start doing that until a little
bit later on um I cuz I felt like At
first you know I just felt like well
they're happy I'll just leave them alone
you know whatever that's their thing you
know um those ignorant
people those ignorant people but yeah um
I I guess it started bothering more late
me more later
because I started dating a Christian guy
you crossed over into the evil yeah and
so to me it wasn't about like hey you
shouldn't believe these things it was
more like you know you're putting
restrictions on yourself like believing
this stuff you know what about all of
this and I start free if yeah isn't that
the argument that Satan used at the
Garden of Eden with tree you have all
these trees to eat from you just can't
it's an enticing argument it's a good
one yeah that ended up being a bit later
I actually went through a lot of
experimental stuff before then um so
after I was pretty like solid on like
yeah Christianity isn't true um it it
kind of made me wonder though like why
does anyone believe anything you know
like why are there witches out there if
if magic work why wouldn't be we all be
doing it right you know like w just like
that or you know why are there like
these monks who meditate for hours and
hours does that actually bring them
peace you know and I had a lot of
questions so um I was very into science
right that's kind of how um also these
like atheist speakers would kind of
present like hey these things can't be
true science yeah and so science kind of
ended up being my arguing point for
everything and so I decided Well what if
I went and I tried to explored like
explore what these people are doing but
tried to use the scientific method on it
of I'll try it out their way and see if
I get results and are they repeatable
you know yeah yeah um so um I I remember
first I went and I went to things that
were closer to
Christianity um so I know that um
Catholicism is very different from
protestantism right but I would I would
see those like gorgeous gigantic
Cathedrals you know like to me that
looked like art you know like amazing
and so I thought well you know maybe
I'll just like go see what a mass is
like I've never been to a mass before so
um I was very into science right that's
kind of how um also these like atheist
speakers would kind of present like hey
these things can't be true science yeah
and so science kind of ended up being my
arguing point for everything and so I
decided Well what if I went and I tried
to explored like explore what these
people are doing but tried to use the
scientific method on it of I'll try it
out their way and see if I get res
results and are they repeatable you know
I thought well you know maybe I'll just
like go see what a mass is like I've
never been to a mass before my first
mass I was like totally confused you
know I saw people touching this water
and doing like like what is that holy
water what is that mean you know and
then I I kind of started exploring um
the Jewish faith because I thought man
you know like maybe there are some
arguments for like some of the stuff in
the Bible but Jesus are you sure he was
the Messiah you know and so I wanted to
know what do the Jews teach about it I
didn't really know a whole lot about
Buddhism or Hinduism or Daoism or any of
those things um I know I started looking
at Eastern religions at that point um
there was a Hindu temple and I did not I
didn't know anything about Hinduism
except I'd always heard they have like a
bazillion gods and you know all this
stuff and so I'm like I knew I wasn't
going to believe that but I was like
well you know I'll go go go see it why
not the experience right I know that you
went to a yoga training school how did
that happen so after my exploration and
all of these things um I actually ended
up right before the yoga um I started
questioning okay but what about like the
Witchcraft thing and I was wondering
like why are there witches out there and
so I remember I went to a library got
some books on the topic and you know so
after exploring all these religious
places this was my conclusion there is
no God this is all fake right um so then
I went and experimented with all this
now the the picture on the right is what
um your typical Wiccan altar looks like
those books on the left those were my
books and I had a lot of books on the
topic um but
I I learned um that there's a lot of
kinds of Witchcraft and so I thought
well on the off chance anything's real
because I'm always open to whatever
right um I thought I would look at wiah
because it claims to be a path of light
no blood magic or weird yeah yeah and so
I thought okay well I'll look into this
so I studied it and um I I created
what's called a book of shadows um and
it's like a witch's journal and so you
write down what you do what the phase of
the moon was the spells that you find
that kind of stuff did you do any spells
I did um on what can you say like I want
that guy at the the street so this is
interesting so it was when I started
getting into this is when I started um
dating the Christian guy who you're
putting a spell on that guy so there's a
song about that practicing Witch is
dating a Christian guy he's dating a
witch and you're dating uh to be fair we
started dating right before I was
looking into this so he didn't know I
was going to get
into I was going to say you know I don't
know if we should have a conversation
with him or yeah he was
uncomfortable with it but he didn't how
you guys meet just real short like not
church so he's he's actually my current
husband husband right now too um but I
met him in church when I was 12 so yeah
um he he moved to my area he lived there
for 2 years we were Kitty dating I'd say
you know just being like oh this is my
boyfriend do you like me yes or no yeah
I know exactly see each other but that's
my boyfriend over there yeah yeah I know
exactly and so um uh we were each
other's first crushes a and uh but you
know when I went to I went to high
School somewhere else his family moved
back to where he was from in California
and so we didn't see each other all this
time but um I was one day you know I was
thinking about like man you know like I
wonder like what what he's doing like
all this stuff I found him on Facebook
and I messaged him love it and you know
like he responded right away too he's
like oh hey you know and so like
connected right away and you know of
course I'm like so you seen anyone you
know like yeah so no we were both
singles how old were you at this time um
I was
22 yes yeah so yeah so that worked out
we immediately started crushing on each
other right away so um but yeah so uh at
that time when we were talking I was
still talking like an atheist right um
but I I told him though I was like why
do people believe in like magic and
stuff so I told him I'm going to just
try this out I'm going to use the
scientific method
if it's repeatable if it's concerned was
he like okay no he was like oh well be
careful you know um I think he was
assuming because he knew I was a big
skeptic I think he was assuming I'd try
and drop it yeah um but what have
happening was interesting so I'm I'm
taking no I'm doing like oh there's
different kinds of magic there's candle
magic and you know stuff um with like
taking paper and burning it in a
cauldron and like which by the way I did
have a cauldron it wasn't like in the
movies where these giant things it was
it wasn't green and bubbling it was
about the size of my fist so it was a
baby cauldron not big enough for an
apple you got it in the kitty aisle at
at Walmart yeah and so I I was going to
do it right though so I I looked at all
the instructions I'm like well I don't
want somebody saying like oh well Haley
you forgot this step that's why it
didn't work so I tried all of it but man
I don't know like the Spells and stuff I
felt like I don't know that they're
really working I felt like some stuff
could just be coincidence I tried tarot
like this could be coincidence I'm not
so sure you know I've had it done twice
I me and it was very scarily accurate
well to the point of I was like if this
would have been said to me two years ago
it couldn't have been true like it was
saying that I was in trouble with the
law and was going to get off off on good
behavior and I'd never been in trouble
with the law but at that moment I was on
probation and I got off in 6 months
instead of two years W and I was just
like yeah and then another one was like
okay there's you're trying to choose
between two women one's blonde one's
berett I was like okay this is like
really like wow well and see that's the
thing a lot of people experiment with
this stuff and get results I was not so
much um I even like built a little altar
you're supposed to choose like a God and
a
goddess um like the moon or something um
yeah so like for you could go and look
at any Pantheon of gods and goddesses
and I was thinking well I want to choose
one of knowledge because that's what I'm
seeking from any religion yep from any
religion that's interesting Jesus well I
found there were Christian Wick yeah so
they had they had Jesus and Mary as god
and goddess this world doesn't surprise
me anymore and they son and mother why
are you gon to have a god and goddess
that yeah I don't know man well I
remember seeing those people and they
were trying to like defend what they
were doing I'm like I'm not even
Christian I'm kind of like are you sure
about this but I I don't know I wanted
to work with like gods and goddesses of
knowledge and stuff but I wasn't getting
a lot of response so I decided to just
do you can also do this just general the
goddess who's represented by like the
moon phases right and then The God Who
is the horned God it's masculine and
feminine energy and so I'm like okay
energies we'll do energies so I'll take
the Horn
Guy what's his name Nat TOS okay yeah a
lot of people like to use bamet to
represent him I did not um I used a
black and white candle for the god and
goddess but um yeah so I did not get
results that I thought were very
good or good enough for me with
practicing witchcraft but but I did
start experiencing some really weird
stuff so I remember Supernatural things
yeah so like things that I placed
wouldn't be where I placed them but I
thought well I'm just like forgetting I
don't know and but what really got me is
one day I was in the house by myself and
I was living at my dad's at the time in
California and so so dad was at work and
I'm on the couch playing video games so
I'm like all into my game and but I like
feel a presence and I think I hear
something moving and so I think my dad
must be home and so you know I take off
my headphones and I'm like Dad and I
don't hear anything and I'm just like
hello you know like what what was that
and so I wait and I feel the presence
but I don't hear anything anymore I just
feel it and I'm like okay that's weird
but from that point in the next several
months it felt like something was
following me like it was like this heavy
presence on me and I had like a lot of
weird experiences that like okay for
example there's um there's Wiccan
holidays the pagan holidays right and
there's like different rituals you do
for that that's where I got the most
spiritual activity like Halloween and
like that kind of stuff um
you know uh I weird stuff was happening
and you know I create my circle uh my
salt Circle and only good spirits are
allowed in that is how it's supposed to
go right and whatever you invite only
what you invite can come in and so you
know I'm thinking okay well the things
that are trying to lead me to truth can
come in then right and so like weird
stuff starts happening with like the
objects in my circle and I'm like oh
there's something here that's crazy and
you know like I saw it though and so
that's why to me I'm just like okay I'm
definitely not an atheist anymore I I
went agnostic because I don't know what
is going on but I knew wow there's like
definitely like beings we can't see out
here and they are interacting with me
that's crazy and um so here's the thing
though right I decided like I was
continuing to practice for a while but I
decided wika is a lot of work okay like
you have to do like all of this like
take care of the altar stuff and do all
these rituals I'm just like H it's so
much work for not a lot of results and
so I kind of like put it on the back
burner and um so that's when I started
focusing on okay what do I want to do
with my life like a career or something
and so you know I'm trying to get more
fits so I'm like okay I'm going to go to
this gym I see they have yoga which I
had always heard is good for
anxiety and depression and it's a gentle
exercise so you don't have to be super
experienced in working out or anything
so I started going I really liked it um
I noticed that okay so it was actually a
Christian place I was learning yoga from
um it was a college and uh so I wasn't
attending the college I was just using
their gyms class
and just so you know there's no such
thing as Christian Yoga and we have
videos on that do not we're not
promoting that at all yes so um but it
seemed spiritual right I I don't think
yoga instructors ever say it's not you
know um but it it like the wording for
things like you know feeling these
different energies the
Universe um stuff like that right and
only yeah right yeah and so uh I liked
it though and um so I kept going for a
while eventually the teacher there um
who we became friends um she she was
like Haley you're really good at this
have you ever thought about teaching it
and oh I've never thought to teach it
but I like it so that could be a fun
career path so that evening I went home
and I looked up to see like you know how
do you go to school for that right well
there was an actual Yoga College which I
didn't even know was a thing oh um and
it was nearby and so um signed up and
I'm I'm expecting I'm going to go in
here I'm going to learn anatomy and
physiology I'm going to learn how to
teach people stretching I'm going to you
know so I go in there and the first
thing that we're taught is actually okay
so let's let's talk about what m is and
the description that was given is m is a
lot right it's the universe it's the
sound of the universe it's God it's you
know the energy that's in me and you and
and they start talking about like the
different chanting and stuff which we
chanted every
class um I didn't know what well I
didn't even know what we were chanting
when it was happening I learned
later um that what we were chanting it
was that um the the god the universe god
um would like influence us um so that
way we could understand him and you know
become one with him and I didn't know
that that's what we were chanting not
that it would have bothered me at that
time anyway but see they're they're
teaching us all this stuff and I'm
thinking okay I really don't care I'm
here to teach people exercise and so you
know I'm just kind of ignoring a lot of
it um
and it's it was a process though you
know I'm attending this for like a long
time and I start noticing that a lot of
the stuff they're saying they start
talking about energies more and how like
these different yoga positions it's kind
of like yoga is like um uh inner Alchemy
right is how they would like word that
inner Alchemy like um you're moving
energy certain ways almost like uh taii
yeah yeah yeah and um so you know but it
was actually having an effect on me
because I thought you know what a lot of
this doesn't
sound foreign and I realized why a lot
of the stuff they were teaching is stuff
that I learned in New Age and so I was
like oh maybe there's something to this
then you know because I started exper
experiencing spiritual stuff in New Age
and then they're teaching a different
kind of new age um but of course I
learned right yoga is one of six
Orthodox schools of Hinduism and you
know I had gone to that Hindu temple I
was like yeah there's no way I could
ever believe something like that right
but I I started to see why somebody
could I couldn't believe the bazillion
Gods kind of thing but if you tell me
all those gods are actually IM of the
same God this is his different parts
right um I could believe that that's a
lot easier which is a counterfeit of I
believe that Jesus being the expressed
image of God is who is actually um
interacting with the creation and and
you know the Bible describes him as the
angel of the Lord maybe he appeared to
the angels in that form or whatever
right so it's like this is the
counterfeit of that reality that um I
think that they're literally going
there's just different aspects and we
see these different sides of them and
300 million what did your boy friend
think of all this during this time so he
kind of saw that I wasn't doing as much
of the witch stuff which he was kind of
expecting would happen but with the yoga
I mean he was just under the impression
that this was just exercise and
stretching yeah so many people do yeah I
didn't really talk to him a whole lot
about what I was learning in school
because the stuff they were teaching me
I was kind of trying to brush off the
spiritual stuff but eventually it
started ending up in my vocabulary I
think he noticed that um but you know
once again there's a lot of Christians
who practice it so to him he's like well
you know maybe it's fine right I mean
you got Christians wearing like Good
Vibes and all that it's like I know it's
trendy and but it's it really is a new
age thing I think it was blessings that
said um those words that are used um
when you do the different exercises and
the
um poses that they're doing in yoga or
telling a story right so I will tell you
the the most common one right so that
way like if you're somebody who
practices yoga you have 100% done this
move set and whether it's the Christian
Yoga or whatever kind there's Warrior 1
2 and three that's what we call it in
English um in Sans cript it's
verasa and ASA is just a
um verados is a God and um he was he's
mostly known for um a tale where he's
like murdering right and is that the one
that's stepping on the people and they
like body parts everywhere and just
wearing heads on
his um no but he he is like one of those
Gods that's more Super violent portrayed
more like demonic yeah um which by the
way like Hindus do have Gods who are
demons and that's okay in Hinduism so
yeah but um this guy so like you know um
it's it's so Warrior one right when you
like put out your hands like this this
is actually like he's taking his sword
and he's cutting this guy's head off
Warrior 2 you grab the head and then
Warrior 3 you put it on a steak wow and
like that's literally what's happening
and this is I mean like the that's what
I'm saying is like even the Christian
Yoga places are teaching these things
but it's not even just about the
storytelling it's like Hindus use this
to worship that God you know um and so
yeah like um
yoga there's certain set moves right um
you know like sun salutations which in
the original language actually just
means Sun worship y Christians like to
be like oh the son like the Son of God
we can just worship the Son of God but
like the Bible in a bunch of places says
God says do not worship him like the
pagans
so we can't do that but good point yeah
yeah yeah so anyway um so I'm in here
I'm learning about all this stuff I'm
learning Sans cript um and I start
reading the yoga
sutras uh which is like obviously that's
the biggest book in yoga right um and
it's very spiritual very spiritual and
so I can't escape that yoga is spiritual
and now I understood why anyone who
taught it in places that even didn't
seem very religious they have to teach
it spiritually cuz you can't separate
the two was anybody in your family
concerned that you were doing this yes
so actually while I was in
school um my grandmother was writing a
book on the dangers of yoga W yeah so
that was interesting um what what ended
up happening is um by the time I grad
graduated so this is
me um and you can see there's a Buddha
behind me wow um this is when I was uh
giving my little thank you speech um and
my my instructors there congratulating
me um I got I became certified yoga
instructor and um I I remember after
that though in my head I'm thinking okay
now I'm an instructor I need to be the
best instructor I can be so I took a
deep dive into a lot of the more
spiritual aspects of yoga that I had
been ignoring but yeah my grandmother
was writing this book right and so she
did something kind of sneaky right she's
like so Haley so I'm writing this book
about yoga but I need to make sure the
information's correct can you read this
and make sure
that is go grandma
yeah and so I'm like I saw the book and
I'm like I know what she's doing but
okay I'll you know entertain it I'm not
afraid of the truth whatever it is right
and you're you can debunker and you're
flattered that somebody wants to know
your opinion and I think that's some of
the some of the mistakes that we make as
Christians when we go to share our thing
we assume that they don't know anything
and we all of a sudden just like you
know oh let me share with you what the
real truth is Right rather than you're
an expert in this tell me what you think
about this that's a beautiful approach
it's giving you the respect of like you
are an expert in this area as well yeah
yeah and so I read her book and um
everything she said was correct was she
ever involved in it um she she never did
yoga she I just wonder what what gave
her the desire to write this book was it
because you okay so partly W but but she
used to be um certified and acupuncture
yes so she was familiar with there's
some similarities there um with like
chakras and stuff like that cuz yoga
also teaches chakra stuff and so um so
she looked more into yoga when I got
into it and like was like oh no like I
recognize some of this this isn't good
and um so I read her book and I'm like
yeah it's like accurate but she's trying
to tell Christians why they can't
practice it I'm not a Christian but she
doesn't really realize that you know um
I at one point I had thought like you
know like well maybe but because I
started being a little bit more open to
maybe Jesus was nice you know like
whatever but the thing is is when I was
more involved in yoga they talked about
Jesus too and they're like yeah he's you
know like there's ways to see him right
you know like he's a great spiritual
teacher he is the son of God he's one of
them you know um there's Krishna and
Buddha along with him and you're the Son
of God right and I actually went to
school with a bunch of Christians and
they did not come out of it Christian um
like some of them still say that they
like pray to Jesus but like they pray to
him like as a spirit guide along with
these other gods um so like it really
does affect you like I am guarantee you
these Christians did not go here
thinking that they were going to give up
their faith you know um but yeah so I I
read her book you know I was like yeah I
can't really like say anything you know
she's right she's pointing out a lot of
reasons why Christians can't practice it
and I know what Christians believe and
I'm like yeah I mean if you believe in
Christianity then it wouldn't make sense
to practice yoga um that's what's even
more ironic about Christian Yoga it's
like why do we have to put the word
Christian with it if there was nothing
wrong with it I mean I just don't say
Christian pickle
bow like I'm not arguing for pickle B
why you got to attach Christian in front
of it because you're trying to re make
sense of why you're doing this thing
that's like not compatible yeah and I
guess uh you know in the end I let her
know like yeah uh your information seems
accurate this one picture is actually
this other pose but everything else you
know is is is accurate and um I didn't
like say too much after that right good
try Grandma seed was planning for sure
when she did that um I know this
probably worried her at first but this
was where things needed to go right is I
read her stuff she's bringing out a lot
of the you know like Hindu thoughts of
yoga right and so I thought you know if
I'm going to be a super great teacher I
really need to be all the way involved
in this and so um yogic Hinduism is
easier it was easier for me because
everything that I did worked had results
and I didn't have to believe in a bunch
of gods it's called like an atheistic
branch of Hinduism because atheist
apparently means you believe in one God
when it comes to that yeah um so uh I I
started there were two areas that really
like changed my whole path um and how
deep I got into it I needed to work on
meditation and I needed to try
Kundalini and uh
Kundalini it's like okay so so
meditation the point of that like yoga
means to yoke what are you yoking to
Brahman the god of the universe the
Universe um you know when you say
namaste right um the god in me sees and
honors the god in you we're all the same
I am you and you are me and we're just
living a different experience
different bodies right um so there's
really like one being in all Brahman yes
so when you understand that if like if
you actually believe that and when
people get to the point where they can
actually believe that there is this
thing that happens um it even has a
name um I'm trying to remember what it
was it was like the Oh The Dark Knight
of the soul the dark KN of the soul is
when you realize you're alone in the
universe because you are all that there
is counterfeit of this is Jesus is the
is the branch I mean Jesus is the vine
we are the branches right we're the
we're the we are connected to him but
not in the way that they're intending
that to be you know what I mean like
there's only one being we're
individuals that are all part of this
family together what's odd about that is
in
in is in parts of I think it's Hinduism
there's a cast
system yeah so if we're just the same
how can you have a cast system so that's
why there's different branches of
Hinduism there's different opinions that
kind of like denominations make sense
yeah yeah it's like different
denominations well if you think you're
rich you're rich you know maybe if you
think you're in a different class maybe
move to the different class well and so
with this um with the meditation right
um the point of that is so I'm trying to
empty my mind but it's not just to be
blank it's because I'm trying to make
room for right the universe Spirit what
what I actually am to come through me
right to be able to speak through me say
things through me you know all this
stuff right and so um I I really worked
hard on that um you have to destroy the
ego the ego is you it's your personality
it's who you are but this teaches that's
not really who you are that's a
construct right A lot of people get rid
of that through DMT and uh iasa like
once once they do that experience
they're like my ego's dead like I I am
those people walk away a completely
changed person after that experience
yeah and well for me I also so I I
didn't get like heavy into drugs but I
did do marijuana and so the thing though
is is that's a big thing to use in the
yoga community and that's not by
coincidence because The God Who
supposedly created yoga is Shiva and
shiva's plant is marijuana and so um
there's like really devote followers of
Shiva who use that and getting high like
that helps them feel like one with the
universe so you can kind of like do that
right so it opens your mind in those
ways and um so I remember I would like
try to get high and meditate um and it
was helping me be able to clear out my
head actually um lightly High I got no
thought at all depending on how your
mind works yeah yeah you're probably
just really deeply intensely looking at
this thing going what am I involved in
yeah well and and so um I guess like I
started seeing everything in front of me
as an illusion like the thing is I
started listening to Hindu Swami talking
um they have their own apologetics and
so I started listening to them and um
you know they were saying stuff like hey
you know let's use science to talk about
this when you see this table right it's
not actually solid on a molecular level
moving so this to say it's solid that's
like an illusion and so they're trying
to like compare these things with
science speed up the molecules it'll
turn no when they're getting out is it
molecularly there's actually more space
than there is matter yeah so thing they
they would use a lot of science to try
to explain things and I connected with
science well and I was already
experiencing how well all of this worked
for me like
spiritually um when I
was successfully being able to clear my
mind successfully being able to see
stuff like an
illusion um which by the way also
learned some of that like seeing things
as an
illusion um from the selfhelp
industry the the
self-improvement like the secret um I
read the Law of Attraction um and that
kind of stuff um I I was always like I
want to be the best at what I'm doing so
I would I thought I was just looking at
like oh this guy you know he's like how
he went from nothing to being like a
millionaire and you know all this stuff
but I didn't realize how many people who
are really successful in in the industry
they they are very um manipulative well
yeah right well they also believe a lot
of spiritual things you know and yeah
see once again to the effect that it
doesn't matter what you are doing in
life you are spiritually connected to
something yeah and you know there's I
could I could go on about all the
reasons why the law of attraction is not
true and very proven not to be we have a
video for that we're going to put that
right here in the top of the screen cool
um yeah so so anyway um I'm able to
successfully do that so then I
experienced something totally different
um I when I'm talking to somebody I
remember I started talking to somebody
and I was trying to explain to them like
these yoga Concepts and I felt like I
wasn't like the words coming out of my
mouth it didn't even sound like me I
didn't feel like I was talking in fact
it was really weird because it I felt
like looking through my eyes was looking
through a TV screen like I'm watching
what's happening I'm not doing any of
this and so to me that was a success
though like oh this is the point this is
you know like the universe talking
through me illusion anyway yeah yeah and
so so I felt like it was working and
then also I would talk to people um
people who I didn't know very well and I
knew things about them and like stuff
was like being fed and to my head like
this person went through this thing talk
to them about this thing and uh you know
some of us like oh really so so I go
there right and then the person's like
how would you know that about me and to
me I'm thinking in my head well this
makes sense if I'm them and you know
they are me you know like some some
level of me knows that because I'm also
them and so to me none of this was weird
um and so I I started living life like
it it felt like I was living life like
two different people you know there was
the me I'm trying to get rid of and then
there's this thing that's totally just
taking over and speaking through me and
leading my life and it's crazy because
the whole argument for you know not
wanting to follow God's rules and stuff
is I want to do my own thing I'm me I'm
free but now it's like no I'm I'm
striving to let someone else make me a
puppet mhm well and there are speakers
out there who are pro meditation Pro
yoga they teach these things right and
one of them I remember listening um he
was talking about meditation and he's
like when you get good at this here are
the things that people don't tell you
that are going to happen but it's okay
don't worry about it right and you know
he was saying like yeah you you'll you
may start to see Angels and Demons you
might start to know things about people
and you're like how do I know this you
may feel like a puppet that's what
actually said being controlled by a
puppet master he's like but that's okay
it's part of the process I mean people
need to hear people need to hear that
more because the the complaint against
Christianity from the non-Christian
world is you're just under control uh no
there are a lot of other things in this
world that are trying to control you you
do drugs those things are controlling
you right you do this that you know you
got stuff starting to take over and
speak through you right you start doing
witchcraft that's will control you well
and so like with the Kundalini right um
it's part of getting really good at that
meditation too so you know um it's
Kundalini is a serpent right serpent
energy that's supposed to go up your
spine and into your head right and
that's the goal you want it to do that
it opens all your you have to open up
all your chakras all this stuff right
but if if the serpent gets into your
head that what was happening to me is
what will happen to you you know and
other people have had like all sorts of
crazy stuff happen with them right um
this is just my experience I think the
thing um that was really interesting so
I started I was teaching yoga right I
was teaching this to people but I was
also teaching Christians and I had
learned in school there are keywords you
use to be um all religion friendly right
so the people who you're going to scare
off really quickly are like Christians
and Muslims and stuff if they hear you
say the wrong thing right and so um you
know I'm trying to like figure out how
do I open these Christians Minds up
without you know like being offensive or
you use the word spiritual yeah well and
I was trying to be helpful and that's
the thing right is like um I when when
yoga instructors are doing this they're
not trying to hurt you you know they
think that they're helping you see
reality for what it is you know they
don't see that is
deceptive um so this is this is what
it's like right when I was doing
that um I the reason I didn't see that
as deceiving someone is because I was
telling them you know like here's this
thought basically now sit with it you
can come up with your own conclusion
right so I wasn't like telling them
directly so I felt like well is it de
seed if they're the one who do
besides it's like putting medicine in a
peanut butter and giving it to the dog
it's like it's deceptive but you know
you're helping the dog so it's like
these narrow-minded Christians are never
going to let me help them so I need to
change my terminology well that whole
philosophy is is well at least in modern
times is in Jesuit because it's the idea
that The end justifies the means right
yeah you know so I can do whatever I
need to do because I'm accomplishing
this greater good be a liar as long as
it's right people which is terrible MH
yeah and so for me I was just thinking
well whatever whatever I can do to help
them open up their minds to what reality
is and so um I it was interesting um
there's all sorts of stuff I can go into
that but that's what my book is for so
yes we going to put a link in the
description where to get this book you
can nerd out on every detail of this an
evolution of faith and my name is Haley
Wolf with an e at the end I want to know
at this point what what brought you back
to Jesus oh man okay so here's the crazy
thing I was so entrenched into this this
was my life right and I started working
at a Christian bookstore um you're you
are all over the board woman so so I was
thinking I'm making money teaching but I
need some more like side income and I
love books so part time yoga instructure
part time Christian Book Sales well well
and this is this is the thing though and
I'm this's on righteousness by faith
you'll really like this one right and
and so this is the interesting thing
right is so I started to work at this
Christian bookstore but okay
Christians like they they would not have
understood the way I saw everything in
there I was not offended by any of it
I'm just like you know this is what they
think they see God is real but he's not
what they think he is right and so I
would see stuff we decorations right you
know be still and know that I am God
yeah be still like meditation and know
that I am God and this is how I was
seeing these things so it didn't bother
me they interview you at this job you
knew all the Christ chrisan maybe if you
are the manager of a CH you might want
to vet out the people coming in your
door to sell your stuff and see this is
the thing right is I told them about my
background so I was like yes I was
raised Christian my grandfather owns
this TV station you know
yoga right word ironically your last
name became wolf I know right yeah so so
um so I'm working at this Christian
bookstore it is not influencing me
whatsoever though like for anyone who
thinks that because of I was working in
there no I was seeing that like just how
I described right like book are full of
scure yeah and so so to me it didn't
have any effect on me in fact I was in
there trying to be like hey I'm a yoga
instructor if you ever want to you know
right yeah yeah and so um so what
happened though was is uh so I'm totally
entrenched right um I go outside for my
morning
meditation and something was different
but I don't know why I would have been
questioning anything at this point
because I hadn't been this whole time um
but I went and I sat down and I had the
thought like I'm looking at this tree in
front of me and it's so pretty and it's
just a gorgeous morning and I'm thinking
like am I really that like is this
really an illusion and I hadn't
questioned that like at all at this
point and so it was strange for me too
but I I decided to open myself up to
just just in case I'm wrong just in case
there's something here I'm missing I
decide to I said um throw something out
to the universe but it was more like a
prayer because it was more specific
right I was very specific with it
because well on you know maybe maybe
I'll get an answer right and so I
said um to whoever it was who created
the universe and everything in it what
is the truth and not a second went by
not any time and I immediately like
echoing in my head was just I am and it
wasn't just like I am it was like the I
am and there was there was no doubt in
my head who was talking to me everything
in an instant that I believed just V
like that like it was like scales fell
off of my eyes and I was like oh my
goodness I'm practicing a false religion
oh my goodness evil exists oh my
goodness like you know like I'm not God
you know all of this stal
crisis and it was just like God woke me
up and it was amazing because no person
was going to get me out of that no
person and I
know I believe the reason why God did
that um I've always been a truth seeker
and I would always accept what the truth
was right but also I had a lot of people
praying for me who were concerned about
what I was doing and what I was involved
in they had no idea how deep I was in it
though and God like rattled the world
for me just then yeah I also it was kind
of crazy because like it's an experience
that is it it makes you so where I 100
100% know who was talking to me I 100%
know what happened and so I believe
that's also God being
merciful CU he knows that I'm like such
a skeptic right and he actually gave he
doesn't do that for everyone right he
actually gave me here I will speak to
you and you will not have no doubt what
happened I did not automatically start
believing that you know everything in
the Bible was accurate or that Jesus was
the Messiah but now I knew where to look
right your mind got placed in the right
direction yes yes and H man it was so
crazy um now I I told my grandfather
when I was telling him this story I told
him luckily I was working out a
Christian bookstore and he's like not
luckily Divine
Providence right so I had all of the
resources I needed so we had a section
called apologetics which is defense of
the Christian faith and so I'm like well
why do Christians believe Jesus was the
Messiah how do we know these things are
accurate I read the Bible cover to cover
and man that book speaks for itself too
right but um so uh because of God's love
because of his Mercy because of his
compassion I am where I'm at and I no
longer teach yoga but I'm still a
teacher I'm teaching other things now
yeah right and um so um when I
discovered all these things and looked
into it and I knew for sure what I
believed I got baptized beautiful and um
my my husband he was still my boyfriend
then he got baptized that same day with
me beautiful and we got married shortly
after a that's awesome yeah yeah so
we're coming up on our Oney year
anniversary now you have a picture of
not on here no no but he's super
handsome and cute but um yeah so um I
tell people this is a rescue story this
is a rescue God rescued me no person
could have done this and so what I do
now is I go places and I speak I think
it's important that Christians know what
yoga instructors are being told to tell
them why yoga is is not compatible at
all with Christianity amen and I wrote
this book here an evolution of Faith um
and so if you want more details about my
story um I actually took notes on these
places that I went these conversations I
had at the end I I talk about these are
the questions I had about Christianity
when I looked back into it these are the
answers I discovered which I also list
things um not just Christian sources but
sources that confirm Christianity
outside of it and so lots of apologetics
in the back um I made I wrote it to be
very um non-Christian friendly so if you
know somebody who's involved in any of
these things or as an atheist or as a
Christian practicing yoga um this is
going to be an easier read for them it's
not a long book and um it's not super
preachy sounding so very friendly I like
how the spirits inside the Apple
computer are not happy about what you're
doing and so they're trying to glitch
out the
TV what a beautiful testimony if people
want to find this book how do they get
this book so I am selling my book on
Amazon right now um it's in paperback
and ebook awesome beautiful beautiful
and I know you're going to come back and
tell your more stories and um thank you
so much for coming and sharing awesome
awesome to hear somebody transform and
what I what I really appreciate out of
this conversation is you you you sought
for truth you're looking for truth
you're going and and actually actively
going I'm going to test this I'm going
to test this that's why God says taste
and test see that I the Lord's ways are
good right taste them try them come
reason with me together and if you seek
God with all of your heart you will find
him absolutely and that is what exactly
happened to you at that moment but I
also love that you brought out the point
that people are praying for for for you
and and you know it's really
revolutionized I believe our work we
pray every single day we have a list
that goes through it in fact sometimes
it gets a little longwinded because the
W list gets a little long but I tell you
what we write it down in a book and we
go back over and we see this book and
we've seen so many prayers answered so
praise God one thing I wanted to bring
about what you were saying not to
contradict you but I think what God is
doing is he's inviting us when he says
taste and see he like try my way first
yes don't don't feel like you have to
try all that I mean they're out there
and God gives us the freedom to do that
you know to explore wiah or yoga or or
atheism or whatever he's really making a
call on invitation to say taste and see
that the Lord is good like I'm calling
you to me that's right I will prove
myself to you and it doesn't mean that
if you go do these other things that God
can't reach you and God can't find you
but he's really asking us start here
first I believe um that's why I believe
Christians really need to learn more
about apologetics Paul talks about how
we have to get be able to give reason
for our faith always have an answer yeah
and there are like there are people who
are like really skeptical like I'd
always been and I believe it's good if
you can give like some really like you
know um non disputable like all this
kind we actually have so much more out
there like a lot of Christians don't
even know how much evidences and proofs
we have for things um the ones that I
list in my book are ones that would have
helped convince me as a skeptic um so
nothing that's kind of oh could be you
know it's like very specific stuff
including
prophecies um which is a big reason to
believe in Jesus actually um when I read
through the Bible I started with you
know I'm not going to look for Jesus in
it I'm just going to read it and let it
speak for itself as soon as you start
getting into the prophecies though it's
like well I'm not even trying to see
Jesus in this and it's like this is so
specific though and there's a ton of it
in there Y and um so I I highly
recommend looking into those topics also
with the taste and see um so uh another
person you had speaking on here Ivan
he's a friend of mine and after I um
woke up to
Christianity I had a little bit of a
crisis I was about to open a yoga studio
and what am I going to tell all my
students you know so I literally had to
go to all of my students and be like hey
this is real I was teaching you bad
stuff please you know let me explain
this some of them didn't want to talk to
me anymore and then others quit doing
yoga
with that's amazing um yeah but that's
the two-edged sword right there yeah but
but Ivan um when I was talking to him um
you know and he's trying to show me like
confirm like hey like these are really
reasons why you cannot christianize this
and he really like opened my eyes from
the Bible I could see it and so I had to
give up my whole career um but um the he
told me though it's it's hard to run
into yoga instructors who practice
Kundalini who quits being yoga
instructors um because Kundalini is
super demonic right like the whole
purpose of it is to be possessed right
and like I said no person got me out of
this it had to be God himself right and
so while it's true like you know you
could do what I did and you could go
look at all these things I really don't
recommend doing that first I recommend
exhausting your resources with
Christianity go look into apologetics it
is real um because you may not be able
to get out of some of that stuff when
you get in it yeah I had such a similar
experience in my life the same thing you
know I I grew up Christian but I kind of
just accepted it and I started having
all these skeptical questions weren't
getting good answers but you know I if I
I don't know I just wish I would have
had all the resources that we have today
because it might have saved me and I
don't want anyone else to have to go
down the road that you and I did by
testing all these things and so I just
pray that this testimony was a blessing
to you if you know anybody that's a
skeptic they can read this book and it's
not going to be preachy it's just going
to be showing evidence for why
Christians have the the right to believe
what they believe in that there's facts
and evidence out there and uh just thank
you so much for coming on the show if
you were blessed by this give it a
thumbs up it really helps our Channel it
helps this video reach other people if
you've never subscribe to this channel
click the Subscribe button and the
notification Bell and we have a show
every week so we will catch you guys
next week bye
[Music]
I'm sorry do we know each other seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you really wish
I had a conversation
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
fin my Breen be strong in the Lord and
in the power of his
mind put all the whole honor of God that
you may be able to stand against the Ws
of the
devil therefore take up the whole h of
God that you may be able to stand
against the walls of the devil
[Music]